Speaker 1: Hey, this is this is almost beyond
parody. Donald Trump's former chief of staff,
Mark Meadows, is being investigated for voter
fraud. And Mark Meadows wife appears to have.
Incorrectly, illegally, fraudulently filled out
voter registrations, you've got to see this,
this is just unbelievable. After arguing for six
months that Democrats were going to cheat and all
of these voter registration things, all this
different stuff and then claiming the election
was stolen by Joe Biden. Salon is now reporting.
Mark Meadows under investigation for alleged voter
fraud in North Carolina. Macon County, D.A.
A. Meadows, ally refers potential prosecution
of Trump's ex chief of staff to the attorney
general. This is unbelievable. Meadows, who
helped spread Trump's debunked voter fraud claims,
may have committed voter fraud himself in 2020.
Trump's former top aide and his wife, Debbie,
registered to vote in what has been called the
Dove trailer in a remote rural area. Meadows does
not appear to have spent a single night there.
According to the report, local news outlet WRAL
later reported that Meadows and his wife voted
via absentee ballots in North Carolina
in 2020, sparking a state investigation.
State Attorney General Josh Stein's office
asked the State Bureau of Investigation to
investigate alongside the Board of Elections
at the conclusion will review their findings.
This he seems to have done the thing
which they said everybody else on the
Democratic side is doing. Meadows listed
the scaly mountain mobile home address and
a voter registration field that asks for the
residential address where you physically live.
Mark and Debbie Meadows sold their prior North
Carolina home when Meadows joined the Trump
administration. Meadows is also registered
to vote in Virginia, where they own a condo.
The former owner of the mobile home told WRAL
they had rented the property to Meadows family,
but said the former Trump aide never spent a
night down there and that Meadows wife only stayed
for a night or two. Then there's a report in The
Washington Post about Debra Meadows, Debra Meadows
appears to have filed three false voter forms.
Speaker 2: Look at this. Look at this
Speaker 1: on her one stop application provided
this week by the North Carolina Board of Elections
to the Fact Checker, Debra Meadows certified. She
resided in a 14 by 62 foot mountain top mobile
home for at least 30 days, even though she did
not live there. At the top of the form is a notice
that quote fraudulently or falsely completing this
form is a class one felony. Oh, this form is the
latest in a string of revelations concerning the
former chief of staff. Who echoed Trump's claims,
false claims of election fraud in 2020, and his
wife, The New Yorker, first reported that Marc
and Debra Meadows submitted voter registration
forms, listing their home as a mobile home with
a rusted metal roof that sold for one hundred
and $5000, even though they never lived there.
North Carolina officials announced that Meadows is
under investigation for potential fraud. Now this,
this is like the key part here. The fact checkers
reporting shows that in 2020, Debra Meadows signed
three forms a voter registration form, an
absentee ballot request for her husband,
and the one stop application that warned of legal
consequences if falsely completed and signed. She
also cast a ballot in a 2020 primary runoff, using
an address that was no longer valid for voting.
Meadows appears to have signed a voter
registration form. He did not vote in the primary
guys. The calls are coming from inside the House.
You know, it has been a decade now at least,
of Republicans regularly accusing others of the
things they are actually doing. And it's almost
like a technique. It's it's like an investigative
technique for us. If we hear from Republicans
that Hillary would not be trustworthy with
sensitive, private and classified information
or email, we should at least explore whether it
is they who cannot be trusted. And of course,
we find out Jared's using private
email for White House business.
Ivanka's using private email from White House for
White House Business. Trump is spilling secrets to
a Russian spy recruiter in the Oval Office. Trump
is eating papers, flushing papers 10 to 15 times,
reportedly. If they're saying that Democrats are
doing it, we should at least investigate whether
it is actually them that are doing it when they
say, Well, we are going to have Democrats do all
sorts of voter fraud. While we should be really
careful that you're going to do the voter fraud
and that you're going to spread lies about the
election and it has essentially come down to
listen. The election was we know the election
was rigged because because we did it,
that that is where we have fundamentally
fallen here and Meadows should be investigated,
his wife should be investigated. And listen,
I know that none of us, if you've been
paying attention to the two tiered justice
system in this country for the last decade,
you would be reasonably situated to question
whether Mark Meadows will face any consequences
regardless of what he did, even if he did
it, even if they've got him dead to rights.
It's not super likely he's going to face any real
consequences. Meanwhile, there are people who just
accidentally voted that they weren't supposed to.
They were like on probation, you know, parole or
there were certain situations, often low income
people who sometimes end up in prison, you know,
so we it is. This entire voter fraud thing is not
only illuminating because they are the ones doing
it, but they accuse everybody else of doing
it. But it's also notable because it exposes
that two tiered justice system where despite the
people getting caught, continuing to be mostly
Republicans, the penalties are almost completely
absent. It. It's depressing. I'm with you.
But we should understand that if they
are repeatedly talking about something,
we should very closely look at whether
they themselves are the ones doing it.